hello I'm the Nostalgia guy remember it
so you don't have to a lot of us grew up
with Tiny Toon Adventures the kids show
that makes child-friendly humor with
Looney tune style adult jokes it started
Warner Brothers hot streak of hit shows
and gave us some colorful and memorable
episodes but did you know that 25 years
ago
to this very day actually this week but
still creepy there was an episode that
was written by kids three thirteen year
olds to be precise some of you might
even remember it kind of stood out from
the other episodes it was called Buster
and Babs go Hawaiian and began with
Buster and Babs actually being told that
the episode was being written by three
teenage girls Renae Carter Sarah Creek
and Amy Crosby the episode seemed odd to
say the least but still funny but a lot
of us were wondering how much of this
was actually true were there really
three kids that were allowed to write a
script for a popular TV show was this
just a made-up story an excuse to get
more PR or some kind of in joke
speculation conspiracy swept the
Internet the conspiracy of course that
the internet didn't exist yet well I
have with me one of the writers who
claims to have written this episode live
via Skype is Rene Carter hello Renee hi
Renee if that is your real name explain
to us how the process of writing this
episode with your friends all took place
well it didn't really start out as a
script it actually started out as a
drawing that I was just kind of doodling
at lunch in the cafeteria one of my
friends had actually made a comment
about that at which then the ax sparked
the idea for the story and of course
this is like number two pencil on
notebook paper it was about as you know
as eighth graders are going to get it
were these drawings like literally that
just drawings or was it like a comic
when I had word bubbles inside yeah just
kind of draw use with word bubbles it
wasn't anything that's organized that I
would actually call a comic you expect
me to believe that you ingeniously did
what the original Looney Tunes animators
did we're instead of writing a script
they just did a bunch of drawings like
storyboards and then eventually turned
that into a cartoon so
you kind of know what you're doing even
when you don't know what you're doing
don't patronize me Rene but managed to
find an address for the local Fox
affiliate we didn't understand about
syndications typed up a letter to go
with it
forgot to sign the letter threw
everything into an envelope and mailed
it we had no idea it was going to be
made in an episode we weren't gonna for
that it was something that we did for
fun it was passed along from one
envelope to another and either we're
doing that either out of the goodness of
their heart or didn't know what they
were doing and passed it on and you know
it got to the right people so how did
they let you know they were gonna make
an episode out of your script
well Warner Brothers or in this case
gene mccurdy first called
and just kind of said you know we got
this story and you know we really
enjoyed it and just you know want to let
you know that she and Barbara Broglie
Adi who was also staff for the show flew
out to my house and that was when they
first told us that we're going to make
this actually into an episode and Nina
we want you to be part of the process
and if they were going to actually fly
us out there and meet with the writers
and meet with feel Berg and you know and
have a chance to all these things so
tell me about going to Hollywood meeting
the writers and being Steven Spielberg's
new best friend
I'm assuming you two were still like
this they really set up a whole
itinerary for us Family Matters or
benefit taping of that Six Flags you
know magic mountain we did all that
stuff that all kind of culminated then
and in meeting with Spielberg we then
had the whole story meeting with as far
as I can remember most if not all of the
the staff writers were there and
approximately 10 million camera people
following us around the whole time and
we had a chance then to kind of you know
sit and go through the preliminary
script that they had sent to us and
threw out ideas and you know and go
through the whole process tell me you
were woman enough to demand the changes
you wanted to the Sprint and you didn't
let any staff write or kind enough to
let you be their push you around we had
input we had things like okay you really
need to keep this in because you know we
thought this is really funny or we're
trying to kind of explain where
something came from I just remember just
kind of everybody bouncing off of
everything else idea wise I just thought
laughing like you know just non-stop I
just remember a great deal of fun you
know more than more than anything else
with that whole meeting do you remember
any of the writers in particular let's
see
I know Sherri stoner was there I
remember because yeah they were telling
us that she was you know the the
live-action reference for area on the
whole mermaid and that kind of stuck in
my mind
what's a strange seeing yourself as a
cartoon character and hearing someone
else do your voice yeah I mean there's
nothing normal about seeing yourself as
a cartoon characters I dabbled in anime
myself it's kind of like you're seeing a
caricature he always had that moment of
you know wait I was like that although
ironically at that time I had an outfit
exactly like the one that I'm wearing in
the cartoon and that was a little creepy
because I mean it didn't actually wear
that at the time we thought at first
that maybe we were going to get a chance
to to do our own voices but the
logistics of that just didn't work out I
didn't find out until later that it was
apparently Cree summer who was doing my
voice which is pretty awesome appliance
day now back to work did she listen to
your voice at all and try to get it down
I have no idea at the time we were sort
of half amused and have irritated by the
southern accents that we were given high
arches best leave them in our script so
I don't know how much listening they
were doing or just kind of like okay do
a basic 13 year old girls voice for you
always messing with the writers vision
in the episode the first third is
setting up the concept with Hampton
getting pushed out of his big episode to
make way for your episode and
Spielberg's real voice interacting with
everyone and such was that always in the
original script because mad props if you
have the proud ego to do that most of
that was added by the other writers
later in as kind of the actual script
was developed what we sent in was
basically just like the base story yeah
they were good about by keeping us in
the process we got copies of the you
know the later script and everything and
obviously they had to Pat it out a lot
to get you know a full episode out of it
I of course had to ask what was
Spielberg like at the risk of sounding
cliche he was awesome come on please
don't you have any dirt on him
but he does he's like the world's nicest
director you know there's a reason all
the people the Oscars are thanking him
you know he took us seriously and you
know when you're 13 that's that's a big
deal so why do you think he as well as
the other producer said yes to making
the script well do you do you want the
the cynical answer or her or the
egotistical answer that was brilliant
well like most writers biga tist eclis
cynical honestly it was great PR for
them I mean we we knew that even at the
time doing all kinds of interviews you
know print interviews you know People
magazine 20/20 it was good for them I
would like to think that what they also
said at the time was was true which was
that this was kind of their way of
giving back to the fans of the show of
course this was at a time when you know
they didn't have as close of a
relationship potentially with fans and
creators that you do now so you know I
think it was a little bit of both what
are your thoughts of this happening
nowadays especially with social media
you think this is something that never
happens or it happens even more I think
it is more likely to happen now because
of social media but of course it's
different you know obviously you still
have you know robust legal departments
that keep some things out but there's
just there's a lot of dialogue that
happens now in both ways and for better
for worse it has pros and cons so
naturally I have to ask are you still
writing
tell me you're the head writer a7d I'm
still writing I write science fiction
and fantasy self-published a few things
had some other things and small presses
I do a fair amount of short stories
drawing art is kind of more of a thing I
do for myself every so often that's
that's a little bit more of a hobby but
it's kind of gone dormant lately well
you've had a very rare experience that
almost no other kids ever had and would
love to have what do you take away from
it one of the things I want to express
is just how grateful I am to you know to
everybody who was involved in that and
just what an incredible experience it
was you know for me you know again
that's something that at 13 you don't
necessarily think
I also you know have another reason to
be thankful because if it hadn't been
for everything that went on with the
show I probably would have never met my
husband lucky duck
he was a fan of the show and wrote to me
and wrote to the three of us actually
and I was the one who wrote back and we
kept sending letters back and forth and
friendship turns into more and we're
actually going to be celebrating her
20th anniversary next year so I'm also
grateful for that tell me you two used
to send Tiny Toon Valentine's to each
other they did used to make those we
used to we used to do quite a bit of
that as a matter of fact I had a drawing
of Buster and Babs on our our rehearsal
dinner invitations we've had a nod to it
well you can see more of Renee's writing
at the link below as well as discover
more about this experience at her blog
Renea congrats to you and your friends
on such a funny episode and thank you
for being on thank you for having me I'm
the Nostalgia Critic I now know about
you but I'm in an even more nostalgic
mood
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing
LIVESTRONG org the LIVESTRONG foundation
fights to improve the lives of people
affected by cancer created in 1997 the
foundation is known for leading an
ongoing dialogue with patients and
survivors providing free cancer support
services and advocating for policies
that improve access to care and quality
of life known for its powerful brand
LIVESTRONG has become a symbol of hope
and inspiration around the world since
its inception the foundation has served
2.5 million people affected by the
disease and raised more than 500 million
dollars to support cancer survivors
being one of America's top nonprofit
organizations the foundation enjoys a
four star rating from Charity Navigator
and has been recognized by the National
Health Council and the Better Business
Bureau for its excellence in governance
you can go to their website or their
YouTube channel to hear so many
inspiring stories definitely go and
check them out
you